matthew whitaker began working for the
federal government way back when equal
justice was the goal
not just a bad joke he in the end became
acting attorney general of the united
states and we're happy to have him join
us
tonight matthew whitaker thanks so much
for coming on tucker
so it seems particularly brazen for them
to just admit you know we haven't done
anything with the hunter blind
investigation because we'd want to help
donald trump that's what politico was
saying
and that's exactly what it appears
happens you know what what it
looks like right now based on everything
we know is that this u.s
attorney in delaware put his thumb on
the scales of justice they knew
that the next overt step was to issue
some
subpoenas and to get documents that
would make the investigation go overt
and what happened is they determined to
affect the election to help joe biden to
hurt donald trump
they decided not to issue those overt
subpoenas
i just think that's so inconsistent with
the way investigations should be
conducted
and the way that we expect and i think
it creates an impression
like you talk about a two-tiered system
of justice where
there is the the left and joe biden and
his family and then there's everyone
else who are
uh you know kind of practically put in
the thumb screws and other
tactics to try to get you know the the
information it's it's outrageous well
that's it right that's it right there
and i just got to be totally honest
if hunter biden never does go go to jail
i won't celebrate i don't celebrate the
jailing of anybody
you know that's not the point it's the
punitive
legal tactics being used against
opponents of the regime that should
scare the hell out of all of us throwing
people into solitary confinement for
trespassing
like it's so disproportionate what does
the doj
i mean there must be people the doj over
thinking well wait a second if you vote
for one guy you go to jail
if you vote for another guy you don't
like that's not justice
yeah the amount of power that
prosecutors have especially at a federal
level is
awesome as you can imagine and it needs
to be used judiciously by
sober-minded people and it can't be used
to
affect elections it can't be used to
target uh our political enemies and
it is it is a shame uh again this is
just a long string of these types of
investigations where it appears
that if you're on the left or if you're
protected
you you get a skate and then at the same
time if you're the cfo for the trump
companies for example
i mean they will go after you until they
find something
to charge you with and it's just it
cannot be and
we we risk losing the republic and i
don't mean to be hyperbolic this is
really this is a moment in time where
prosecutors
both federal state and local need to
determine
are they going after people for their
political beliefs or because that's
where the evidence leads and are we
treating everybody the same and right
now
based on this hunter biden case we are
clearly not treating everyone the same
do you think if i lied on a federal gun
form i'd get away with it
no absolutely not yeah especially not
the trump administration
we went to lie and try uh cases all the
time
yeah i don't think you would either
matthew whitaker thanks so much for
joining us tonight thank you story
really if you think of it that way
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else